questions remain as to why a family dog
killed one of its owners happened
yesterday on pennwood avenue near desert
inn valley view we've learned the victim
88 years old victoria saha joins us now
live in fact she spoke with the victim's
caretaker today who saw it all happen in
an interview you'll only hear on eight
relatives of joan cathill say that buck
was their family dog for about six years
the eight-year-old rescue pit never
showed any signs of aggression but
yesterday something snapped and inside
that apartment over there
carefully's caretaker was left helpless
as the vicious attack unfolded but we do
want to warn you details of this attack
are disturbing
joan caplo and buck are described as
being really close
bach would often cuddle up next to caflo
there'd be no snows on that bed right
there caphall's great grandson damon
faircloth says clathol had dementia it
recently got worse and she couldn't pay
too much attention to buck there's his
toys and his leash right there caretaker
jelena kelly stepped in to help full
time she preferred to not show her face
on camera granny come on we dancing and
then she'll get up and
kind of move around a little bit on
tuesday morning kelly left cafe with
buck in the bedroom as she went to the
kitchen i heard
just like a strange noise
so as i came around here
buck had had granny here
and was dragging her to this room right
here he had her by the neck he had her
by the neck
and was dragging her body
into that the second room right there
kelly says she tried yelling at buck but
nothing worked i'm in the second bedroom
terrified to come out
and i'm opening the door and i'm like
bug but i could hear
him
he had to have her in his mouth and just
because i hear all the bumps kelly
called kathleen's family and 911 right
away he scooted her head back and when i
seen it right there
he she still was alive you know because
she put her hands up kelly says when
police arrived they got a hold of buck
but damage was already done the rule was
a bloodbath girl oh my god his whole
head
was full of blood already kathil was
pronounced dead inside the apartment and
buck was taken away by las vegas animal
control
buck is at the animal foundation on a
legal hold as animal control finishes
the investigation the family tells me
that they do not want buck to be
euthanized victoria saha live local now